by now I'm sure you've seen the nine
minutes of Playstation 5 gameplay
showcasing the Unreal Engine 5 it was
absolutely jaw-dropping but after that
ended Jeff Keely interviewed members of
Epic Games to glean a bit more
information I know that watching
middle-aged millionaires speaking
through webcams is not for everyone but
I loved it and now I can tell you things
that you may have missed some will blow
your mind some are quite informative and
others are little Easter eggs and silly
things like the first one on this list
at the beginning of the showcase brine
carest gave us an overview of what we
were about to see and said this in the
end that's what it's all about art that
just works in the end that's what it's
all about
it just works well are there any
pathetic fans in the house you may
recognize this as something Todd Howard
says when he talks about their game
engine and that became a meme
it doesn't just work Epic Games in
Bethesda don't get along too well so I'm
pretty sure these are shots fired by
Epic Games that just works
number two the PlayStation SSD is
groundbreaking when the PS 5 in the Xbox
series X revealed their stats we were
all pre-programmed
to look at teraflops and immediately
selected our winner all now's the time
to be honest to yourself do you really
know what a teraflop is can you define a
floating point of operations per second
no neither can i but alas we all took
note of that first what many of us
ignored is the PS 5s solid-state drive
and what it offers the Xbox and even PC
cannot let's look into that epic founder
Tim Sweeney said this the hardware that
Sony is launching is absolutely
phenomenal sony storage system is
absolutely world-class not only the best
on console but also the best on any
platform better than high-end pcs wow
those are strong words but what do they
actually mean well let's try and break
this down in a way that makes it
accessible to all of us and keep in mind
I am no tech expert using a solid-state
drive gives us high speed data transfer
the Xbox Series X is so damn fast
allowing 2.4 gigabytes of raw data
transfer and that goes way higher up to
four point eight which is bloody huge if
the data is compressed well get this in
your earholes the PS 5 SSD runs at 5.5
gigabytes per second uncompressed
completely raw data transferred so
quickly load screens may never be a
thing again of course I'm a bit of a
PlayStation fanboy it's in my title but
it is mind-blowing that PS 5 can do far
more than the new Xbox in raw state and
it's even more than the Xbox can do
compressed time will tell if compression
rates will matter but at present this is
beyond what the industry is used to can
I just say I'm not trying to start a
console war here because I'm impressed
by Balt consoles and the direction they
take I'd say the Xbox is the powerhouse
like the juggernaut in x-men
then that would make the PS 5 the Ellen
Page character using speed of thought
of a brute strength hopefully I didn't
offend anyone there but I'm sure I did
I'm expecting PC part manufacturers to
closely monitor how the PS 5 SSD
operates and maybe it will lead to a
change on PC however you look at it
let's be honest the only one is here are
us gamers number 3 creator support both
Epic Games and PlayStation have aimed
their content to assist creators and
people who want to share their content
that's why almost all first party
PlayStation games are given photo mode
updates while epic games went beyond
this and confirmed creator support
similar to that in wot night will be
present in all video games made on
Unreal Engine 5 if the dev wants that to
happen of course it's up to them if they
implement this one of the biggest
additions is a free camera in game epic
have actually added this as a replay
mode in their fortnight game which was
only possible using PC mods in the past
but finally it will be possible for all
creators to make in game movies kinda
like those back in the day like red vs.
blue or the numerous cinematic fortnight
channels this feature will be intrinsic
to Unreal Engine 5 but the only caveat
to that is the team that make your game
have to agree to put it in their game
but it is their fingers crossed they go
for it
number 4 video games and movies combined
there's a definite disconnect between
the fidelity of movies when compared to
video games where movies especially
superhero movies look realistic and
believable
video games never quite get there
recently Kingdom Hearts was able to come
close to toy story's fidelity in the
1990s but that was 30 years ago
he is epics plan they intend to merge
both worlds taking real world scans and
instantaneously placing them in a video
game this has been attempted for years
this isn't new but it's never looked as
good as this before so take everything
with a grain of salt ok but can we just
look at those ps5 rocks for a second WoW
is photorealism finally here the plan
for Unreal Engine 5 is to allow movie
makers the same access as video game
developers to continue to bridge those
two worlds
King everyone work together number 5
sound something which wasn't covered in
much depth in the presentation was sound
design and how it's changed slowly over
years in the interview after the
showcase
they spoke more in depth about this and
it seems to be based on ray tracing
we've covered this in previous video so
I won't dwell here it basically means
when a light hits an object it bounces
around the scene and illuminates other
areas there's a ton of footage of ray
tracing out there the Minecraft video in
particular is really impressive well
epic is using this technology but they
are scaling it slightly so it's
fundamentally the same but much more
affordable and easier to attain on
multiple devices well sound will operate
using the exact same theory and audio
source will be put into a scene and it
will hit objects just like it would in
the real world if you've ever heard an
echo in a cave that's the holy grail
here reflecting sounds for full
immersion in video games and let's be
honest we really need this at present I
cannot tell if an enemy in a video game
is above me or below me I cannot wait
for better audio in video games number 6
there's a fortnight Easter egg did you
see it epic games have become the
leaders of video game culture thanks to
fortnight's and whether you think it's
just a kids game or you've opened your
mind and seen that this is more of a
meta verse of content one thing for
certain you've heard a fortnight did you
notice this thing in the background
behind Tim Sweeney he could be simply
trying to make the background more
entertaining but if you played fortnight
you'll recognize what this is alluding
to the doomsday machine which is
currently being built in the game right
now this isn't a groundbreaking bit of
information but I adore how they do all
this meta mentioning of things the
little things keep us all interested
this was a good touch GG Tim number 7
can we actually trust this demo this is
a great question
can we trust anything we see before we
actually get it in our hands we've been
duped so many times before by everyone
the one which always sticks in my mind
is the time Sony completely faked a kill
zone demo in 2005 supposedly running on
a PS
and he'll know it wasn't lesson learned
don't trust anyone especially the people
you like maybe a mum you can trust your
mum so with that all running through my
mind I checked back on the ps4 Unreal
Engine 4 demo from seven years ago to
see if everything was attainable and
guess what as promised everything in
that demo I believe has been achieved in
the last seven years
you can even argue that we've gone far
beyond this jumping back to 2020 and PS
5 and Unreal Engine 5 we have to decide
this for ourselves they promised us this
is coming straight out of a PS 5 dev kit
and from our research history supports
the honesty from Epic Games and Sony
when in partnership so yeah I totally
believe this is real and I can't wait
for the future and finally number 8 epic
games are great you may see this as me
fanboying again but for transparency's
sake I used to be a games design
lecturer and Unreal Engine 3 was my BAE
who epic announced that the Unreal
Engine is royalty-free now until a game
reaches a whopping 1 million dollars in
revenue so if you're ever thinking about
making a video game and you don't want
to shell out any money to start the
Unreal Engine has you covered my stats
may be a little off here but back when I
was using it when a game made $3,000 in
1/4 5% of that went straight to epic
games now it's all profit for you until
you become a bonafide millionaire if you
have the time and the passion to make a
video game there's nothing holding you
back anymore
well except a hulking great PC and
coding skills and art abilities and idea
ok yeah I didn't think that through but
hey it's still a great opportunity to
make video games so there we have it 8
things you may have missed in the PS 5
gameplay reveal by epic games running on
the sublime Unreal Engine 5 the engine
will be in general release next year and
fortnight being the trendsetters they
are will be the first game to switch
over if you've stayed this long please
write super nintendo gang in the
comments and I will find you thank you
very much for your time I really
appreciate it I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
[Music]